hey everyone eric boss here in the new
rockstars blue dungeon
it's happened we have marvel news loki
has an
official trailer god bless kevin feige
and god bless tom hiddleston because he
might be god now
i didn't have time to set up this uh
blue dungeon setup to react to it i
actually had to sit down at my desk you
got to see the other side of the blue
dungeon like you you are just going to
see my live raw reaction
super raw and then on the other side of
it i'm going to be back here
without this stuff and i'm going to give
you my first thoughts on this trailer
before of course i do
my classic full in-depth deep dive of
all the interesting visual details that
they hid in this trailer here it is my
reaction i'm gonna make
two hour long video on this
so an end game scene great
like tony stark
okay there's more good you're taking me
somewhere to kill me
no i'm taking you someplace to talk door
where i don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did
because we both know you love to talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up
glorious
what am i looking at
roxcart
this looks beautiful
more jumping out of planes
not this
okay uh i am um doing this bootleg style
here
in the uh blue dungeon um reacting to
what we saw in this loki trailer
pretty nuts right like this feels a lot
like thor ragnarok right in terms of its
bright
vibrant color it's playful manic energy
we start with
loki strewn in the sands of a mongolian
desert it looks like
very reminiscent of tony stark's escape
from the
cave in uh the first iron man movie also
it reminds me of like
ben linus and lost when he just like
showed up in the middle of the desert
it's like yeah
the allegory of the cave you were
trapped in the cave now you reach
enlightenment once you are escaped from
the cave
we get our first look at the tva
headquarters uh owen wilson as a tva
agent i love this uh creepy elevator it
kind of reminds me of the weird retro
world of legion i assume each of these
floors represents a different timeline
in the universe right like they have
different designations fe3
lk3 2w1 fhf there's an x
in there maybe a different x-men
timeline owen wilson's going gray now
looks great he talks about the tva yes
the time variance authority these are
marvel's time cops the bureaucrats who
monitor the different timelines of the
universe or i should say
multiverse because these are all
different causalities i think what we're
seeing
is loki being tried for his crimes he
has to make up for them he has to pay
some kind of penance or some sentence
what i love about this is he's brought
in front of this judge with the three
different faces folks i think this could
be
the living tribunal of the marvel
cinematic universe the living tribunal
was basically this cosmic judge
with multiple different faces
representing its impartiality and they
basically give
thanos a free pass in the infinity
gauntlet storyline all the different
cosmic entities try to drag thanos
in front of this court to try to try him
for snapping away half of everything a
living tribunal is like no he's free to
go he didn't break any natural laws of
the universe you guys should have tried
harder and uh the infinity war writers
talked about wanting to bring in the
living tribunal into that infinity war
scene where doctor strange
uh fights thanos and drags him through
the multiverse that was all in concept
art and now i think we may be seeing a
version of a living tribunal
in loki they're the ones who are going
to decide what loki has to do to pay off
his crimes and i think loki's
sentence will be he has to help these
time monitors
track down whoever this villain
character is this hooded figure who
i'm thinking either could be kang the
conqueror but you know when you see a
hooded figure in marvel your mind
immediately goes to
doom if they could introduce dr doom in
this loki series that would be awesome i
know that they have the fantastic four
coming with john watts but they can use
both of these stories to slowly
introduce
the marvel's first family and the
biggest villain in marvel comics in uh
the same kind of movie coming up in the
future yeah he's having to pay for his
crimes you they we get these awesome
projections of moments from the first
avengers movie where he put on that
helmet
he made all the germans bow down for him
and the moment he got arrested
which is fun because that particular
shot is from loki's point of view so
it's like maybe they're scanning his
mind to make him remember these moments
and
he feels traumatized by it so he's like
oh now looks like they're these
chrono monitors these time cops in this
place roxcart which is interesting might
be connected to the roxxx roxon
corporation that has existed in the
world of marvel before
they're like an energy conglomerate but
it looks like they're going to be tied
into whatever this plot this conspiracy
is
i love that we keep coming back to this
elevator this elevator looks like it
could be kind of a nexus point that loki
cannot fully escape he always finds
himself looping back to that
anytime he tries to escape there's this
interesting stained glass shot where it
looks like there is a devil portrait on
the background of that stained glass
that could be a tie to
mephisto someone who also ties him with
this kind of a low-key trickery
loki is a god of mischief mephisto is
just like the marvel's version of satan
if bisco could come into the show that
would be another exciting villain though
i still think mephisto could be tying
into wanavision
we'll see yeah we're seeing some insane
universe colliding imagery here uh looks
like a giant moon collapsing to the
surface
the lady loki character who's at the
base of that looks like the ruins of new
york a giant crater in the middle of
central park you can see the ruins of
avengers tower in the background there
maybe some alternate reality where uh
thanos army was successful in avengers
and now loki's having to visit that and
finally we got some confirmation that
heindall exists and why shouldn't he if
loki
exists in this reality he broke off of
the 2012 timeline and avengers end game
on the other side of that yeah heimdall
would still be alive too because
infinity war has not happened yet or
might not ever happen
in this timeline so we didn't get to see
heimdall here but he does
catch loki mid-air this is like a total
mission impossible style stunt here
leaving some uh looks like cash floating
in the background and our stinger shot
loki wearing it looks like a campaign
pin
uh yeah i'm gonna get me one of them
with these warriors alongside him folks
there is a
multitude of easter eggs to break down
in this i
am going to cover all of it i am so
excited by the way i'm doing reactions
to
as much as i possibly can tonight
definitely go check out our falcon
winter soldier reaction
check out our one division reaction and
check out our full breakdown of all the
big news from this uh announcement
they're gonna be coming out one after
the other tonight it's gonna be a long
night for me
uh and let's have some fun with it oh
and now that marvel has
woken back up from its hibernation you
may have noticed i'm wearing our this is
a way this is a limited edition shirt
that new rockstars is trying to
push out on our merch store we have
official merch that we are making
there are great designs this is what we
call our latest obsession it's a custom
design
that we only have for a limited amount
of time this is one we have for the
mandalorian we're gonna have original
designs for the falcon winter soldier
for wand division and for loki
and you're gonna love how it looks so uh
be sure to check out our merch store new
rockstarsmarch.com obviously subscribe
to the channel new rockstars on youtube
follow new rockstars on all social media
follow me on social media at eavos and
stay tuned for the breakdown of this
it's going to be super long there's a
ton of details to talk about and i'm so
excited thanks for watching
and bearing with this awkward looking
bootleg style there is no time
[Music]
you